corona infizierte neben hildburghausen
gibt es außerdem inzwischen einen
zweiten super hot spot passau startete
mit ausgangssperre in die adventszeit
viele politiker warnen bereits vor einem
langen kalten winter aber wie lange wird
dieser winter wirklich droht uns ein
endlos lockdown und genau darüber wollen
wir jetzt diskutieren mit
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil von
der spd und wolfgang kubicki
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestags
von der fdp und karten sinne man dem
vorsitzenden der mittelstands-union von
csu cdu zunächst aber noch mal den blick
auf diese woche auf den gipfel denn da
lautete das große versprechen der
kanzlerin und der ministerpräsidenten
endlich für einheitlichkeit im corona
regel wirrwarr zu sorgen wie gut das
geklappt hat das wollen wir jetzt einmal
anschauen und wir reduzieren noch einmal
die kontakte damit wir dann zu den
weihnachtstagen vom 23 12 bis längstens
erster januar ein fest im engsten
familien und freundeskreis mit maximal
zehn personen feiern können kinder die
dazu gehören unter 14 zählen auch hier
nicht dann kommt diese weihnachts regelt
des bundes und der bund sagt zehn
menschen können sich treffen und kinder
bis 14 werden rausgerechnet und wir
wollen bei der bundesregelung der
personen korrigieren auf unsere fünf
also fünf personen dürfen sich dann auch
weihnachten nur treffen die klare
aussage von bund und ländern dass die
lage es uns nicht erlaubt die november
maßnahmen aufzuheben
wir haben beschrieben wo es eröffnung
geben kann das ist bei den körpernahen
dienstleistungen kosmetikerinnen
fußpflegerin können ihre dienste wieder
aufnehmen ab montag der familiär
bedingte reisend von touristischen
reisen schwer abzugrenzen sind haben
sich bund und länder in ihrer sitzung
eben nicht darauf geeinigt eine solche
ausnahme bei der nutzung foto fels in
den beschluss aufzunehmen an den stellen
wo das aber doch dann auch vielleicht
nötig ist die engste familie zu besuchen
und weil man sie nicht lange gesehen hat
und diesen besuch jetzt auch wirklich
organisieren will
gehen wir davon aus dass das ja kein
keine touristische reise ist wo man dann
an der stadt in der man angekommen ist
durch die stadt wandelt und sich die
sehenswürdigkeiten anguckt oder shoppen
gehen will und wenn es in einer reise
ist die nicht touristische natur ist
dann gibt es auch eine
übernachtungsmöglichkeit in den hotels
wird natürlich jetzt eine verwandten
reise bewacht und zwar unter diesem und
eching begriff der muss ja auch die
chance haben irgendwo übernachten zu
können nicht jeder die möglichkeit
eigene zimmer zur verfügung zu stellen
also werden wir klarstellen dass wenn
jemand zu seinen kindern fährt muss
irgendwie übernachten dass auch solche
übernachtungen natürlich in den hotels
möglich sind ja man hat gesehen anstatt
klarheit regiert nun wieder die
unübersichtlichkeit wie gefährlich ist
dieses chaos und dieses wirrwarr um die
regeln und auch die kleinstaaterei denn
für die akzeptanz der regeln herr
minister
ich halte das nicht für chaos sondern
dem grunde nach geht es ja erst mal
darum dass wir alle verantwortung
übernehmen abstand halten hygieneregeln
einhalten mundschutz tragen da wo es
notwendig ist und man kann abstand
halten kann und es gibt staatliche
regeln die ein ziel haben nämlich dass
wo immer es geht man soziale kontakte
unterbricht um den virus die stirn zu
bieten um tatsächlich vernünftig mit der
sache umzugehen und da halten sich die
länder auch an die grundregeln es gibt
unterschiede zwischen einzelnen
bundesländern je nach
infektionsgeschehen zum beispiel
zwischen schleswig-holstein und berlin
aber die grundregeln stehen ich bin froh
dass das gelungen ist
glauben sie denn wirklich dass die
bürger noch im überblick haben also
gerade beim thema hotels was ist denn da
der richtige weg dass einige länderchefs
sagen na klar über weihnachten machen
wir die hotels
oft denn da wird keiner reisen aus
touristischen zwecken sondern nur die
verwandten besuchen wir können das alles
wunderbar kontrollieren und die anderen
die sagen er aus dem grund weil es nicht
kontrollieren können machen wir zu also
der appell an die bürgerinnen und bürger
ist klar nämlich weihnachten ist was
wichtiges man will auch verwandte sehen
aber der aufruf ist möglichst nicht so
viele soziale kontakte
es geht ja darum die gesundheit von
menschen zu schützen die gesundheit auch
von angehörigen beispielsweise fällt
vielen sehr sehr schwer mir auch freunde
nicht zutreffen viele verwandte nicht zu
sehen aber daran müssen wir uns halten
damit wir gut durch diesen winter kommen
damit wir möglichst das pandemie
geschehen im griff bekommen das heißt es
geht jetzt nicht um das kleinklein
einzelner regelungen
es geht um das verhalten die solidarität
auch die vernunft von jedem einzelnen
diesem land und darauf müssen wir setzen
in diesem land haben sich so viele
menschen solidarischen vernünftig das
ganze jahr verhalten und wir müssen
jetzt zusammenstehen und abstand halten
so verrückt es klingt um diese pandemie
auch in den griff zu bekommen wollen sie
nicht auf eine seite schlagen entweder
bei herrn stephan weil aus niedersachsen
der sagt hotels dürfen zu weihnachten
aufmachen oder malu dreyer die sagt
neben bleiben geschlossen
ich glaube nein richtig oder falsch das
richtige ist dass wir alle so wenig wie
möglich begegnungen organisieren und so
wenig wie möglich auch reisen das ist
ein appell und dafür gibt es ein paar
regeln und daran sollte man sich halten
und orientieren
herr kubicki was haben sie denn gedacht
nach diesem gipfel und den doch wieder
einzelnen regelungen auf landesebene
führt das dazu dass die bürger immer
mehr den überblick verlieren
in den regelungen in den ländern folgen
wir einer verfassungsgerichtlichen
rechtsprechung die sagt dass sich die
maßnahmen über infektionsgeschehen
auszurichten haben aber dass ihr
unterschiedliches in bayern und
schleswig holstein haben es ja mit
massiven grundrechtseingriff zu tun die
nur gerechtfertig sind werden
gesundheitsschutz nicht mehr
gewährleistet werden kann wenn die
infektionszahlen so hoch sind dass man
die entsprechenden maßnahmen ergreifen
können schließlich war schon ist ein
land mit landesweit an incidents wert
unter 50
bei uns haben ja einige kreise sechs an
der zahl sind unter 20
dort wäre sie gar nicht mehr zu
rechtfertigen das lokale und
hotelbetriebe geschlossen sind
das machen wir aber deshalb bestätigt
holstein das machen auch die hoteliers
sind die gastronomen mit weil wir
ansonsten das gefühl haben dass die
hamburger die niedersachsen die keine
möglichkeiten haben in ihren ländern
unterwegs zu sein da steht in
deutschland kommen würden und das
geschehen bei uns anheizen würden gleich
wurde so bei uns sind die hotels nicht
geschlossen
die hotels sind geöffnet für dienstag
geschäftsreisen und der verordnungsgeber
schleswig holstein hat ähnlich wie er
das für berlin erklärt hat festgelegt
dass zu touristischen reisen keine
reisen gehören die verwandtenbesuche
beinhalten
da müssen eben die hoteliers sehr
sorgfältig darauf achten denn die sind
der ansprechpartner der des
verordnungsgeber aber nach der nach den
letzten monaten des bestehens steht
standen nicht da sehr optimistisch dass
wir keine infektionsgefahren bekommen
durch übermäßiges reisen innerhalb
unseres landes oder von außen unser land
hinein
wir sind bisher sehr gut durch die krise
gekommen und so wird es auch bleiben
herr kubicki sagt gerade die hotels sind
nicht das problem und werden nicht zu
einem überhöhten infektionsgeschehen
beitragen herr lindemann würden sie dann
dafür plädieren dass man die hotels
bundesweit wieder aufmacht also
grundsätzlich ist es immer ein problem
bei grenzüberschreitenden verkehr wenn
man unterschiedliche regelung hat in den
bundesländern das handelbaren
beherbergungs verbot gesehen und ich
finde das sehen wir jetzt auch bei dem
hotel verbot oder übernachtungs verbot
stellen sie sich vor sie haben verwandte
in wiesbaden wir haben herrn bouffier
eben gehört er lässt die hotels offen
für die verwandtschaft muss man einfach
zu formulieren ein paar hundert meter
weiter oder 12 kilometer weiter sind sie
in mainz in rheinland pfalz und dort ist
es verboten
das passt nicht und der andere punkt ist
der es kann nicht sein und das muss man
auch kritisch sagen dürfen
dass man sich mittwochs trifft mehrere
stunden abends gibt es eine große
pressekonferenz
man sagt worauf man sich geeinigt hat
und am nächsten tag scheren die ersten
länder aus beispiel berlin sagt ich
möchte nicht zu weihnachten zehn
personen als höchstgrenze sondern fünf
da sollte man sich ehrlich machen und
dann an den mittwochabend nachdem alle
getagt haben alle ministerpräsidenten
mit der kanzlerin dass man sagt wir
haben ein minimalkonsens das ist der
konsens und am nächsten tag kommt die
regeln der länder
ansonsten haben wir ein kuddelmuddel so
wie wir es leider jetzt gesehen haben
also ich stelle mich nicht vor sozusagen
alle dinge die man auch nicht erklären
kann was wollen wir 1 festhalten ich war
ja dabei bei dieser schalte und die
grundregeln gelten in allen
bundesländern dass man in bestimmten
bundesländern wo besonders hohe
infektionen sind noch darüber hinaus
maßnahmen ergreift wie das michael
müller in berlin tut oder wie das jetzt
zum beispiel in super hot spots mit
burghausen in thüringen oder in passau
passieren muss das ist der lage
angemessen hatte herr kubicki recht es
geht und den begriff der
verhältnismäßigkeit und noch mal bevor
wir es ja alles kaputt treten es gibt
kaum ein land der welt in dem so
vernünftig auch gemeinschaftlich agiert
wird ich wünsche mir auch
einheitlichkeit und übersichtlichkeit
aber es gibt ja keine blaupause und
nochmal die grundregeln gelten in allen
bundesländern das haben auch alle mit
umgesetzt das ist am mittwoch vereinbart
worden
und es gibt je nach infektionsgeschehen
unterschiede und das glaube ich sollten
wir auch mal hervorheben an darstellen
aber herr minister eine sache muss man
schon sagen also vergleichbare basis
grundlagen sollten dann wenigstens auch
zu vergleichbaren regeln führen und
teilweise es ist nicht mehr so ganz
nachvollziehbar gerade bei den hotels
also dass das eine bundesland sagt wir
eröffnen die hotels auch für eben
familienreisen der nenne ich jetzt mal
weil an weihnachten reist man doch
sowieso nur um die familie zu besuchen
und andere sagen nein wir lassen das
geschlossen weil man kann nicht genau
sagen ob es ein touristischer zweck ist
also beispielsweise in rheinland pfalz
können wir nicht sagen ob die leute
einfach gerne meine städtetour machen
also da herr lindemann wo sehen sie denn
da das problem hat die kanzlerin dann
versagt beim gipfel weil sie sich nicht
genug durchgesetzt
hat oder ist das problem dann eher bei
den länderfürsten die dann ein papier
absegnen und am nächsten tag machen was
sie wollen gar nicht gerne natürlich
sind wir gut durch die krise gekommen
auch mit unseren regeln aber wir müssen
aufpassen dass die akzeptanz nicht
schwindet und es wäre glaube ich besser
wenn nach solchen ministerkonferenz mit
der kanzlerin gesagt wird was ist der
minimalkonsens und darauf hat man sich
geeinigt und das steht dann auch wenn
die menschen allerdings am abend etwas
anderes hören als am nächsten tag dann
gibt's halt die probleme und auf der
anderen seite müssen die maßnahmen gut
erklärt werden also entscheidend ist ja
die akzeptanz wir können ja ein
startblöcken fördert mal gesagt ein
bundesverfassungsrichter eingeklebt der
start von regeln die er sich nicht
selbst geben kann und gerade bei dieser
pandemie kommt es auf akzeptanz an auf
eigenverantwortung verträgen wir ja
gleich noch über weihnachten oder andere
themen wo es darauf ankommt dass die
menschen auch in ihren privaträumen
eigenverantwortung übernehmen und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass die dinge
erklärt werden das erklärt wird warum
beispielsweise auf einem
supermarktparkplatz man masken tragen
muss dann beim tanken an der zapfsäule
aber nicht ich glaube das ist total
entscheidend für die akzeptanz und wir
sind deshalb gut durch die krise
gekommen weil wir so eine hohe akzeptanz
haben und das sollte auch so bleiben das
ist mein appell und ich glaube damit
habe ich nicht die kanzlerin kritisiert
sondern sie sieht es bestimmt genauso
vielleicht auch um die akzeptanz zu
steigern gab es ein kleines
weihnachtsgeschenk vorab schon die
ankündigung dass während der
weihnachtsfeiertage ab dem 23 und bis
neujahr gelockert wird ist dann die
ansteckungsgefahr in dieser zeit nicht
so hoch oder warum nein das ist nicht
der fall
tatsache ist damit nicht ganz beim
kollegen lindemann bisher auch keinen
widerspruch aufbauen es geht um
akzeptanz es geht um regeln die
staatlich festgelegt sind an die man
sich halten muss aber der staat kann ja
nicht alles im privaten bereich und
sollte übrigens in einer freien
gesellschaft kontrollieren sodass geht
um das verhalten das gilt auch an den
weihnachtsfeiertagen wenn die
gelegenheit ist verwandte zu treffen wo
immer es geht vorsichtig zu sein
aufzupassen das geht ja tatsächlich auch
um die gesundheit von angehört
um die eigene und das ist ein grundsatz
den kann man nicht staatlich verordnen
sondern der hat was mit
eigenverantwortung auch zu tun aber da
setzt sich auf die vernunft der
bürgerinnen und bürger dass man regeln
hat die irgendwie noch lebenspraktisch
sind und dass es ein bedürfnis gibt am
ende eines jahres ob aus christlichen
motiven oder weil es ende des jahres ist
menschen irgendwie zu sehen auch
verwandte das halte ich für ein gebot
auch ich sag mal der lebenspraxis aber
gleichzeitig gilt es ist nicht so dass
an einem tag sozusagen das risiko sich
anzustecken weniger ist als am nächsten
und wir sind in der sehr sehr ernsten
situation nach wie vor
es geht ja darum die gesundheit zu
schützen aber auch dafür zu sorgen dass
wir irgendwann ein stück für stück
wieder aufmachen können um das leben
auch die wirtschaft wieder voll in gang
zu bringen
und das geht nur wenn wir uns alle
vernünftig verhalten aber es gibt
durchaus sehr kritische stimmen schon
mit blick auf diese festtags lockerungen
nenne ich jetzt mal unter anderem der
vorsitzende des welt ärzte bundes frank
ulrich montgomery dieser sagte diese
woche medizinisch epidemiologisch ist es
wahnsinn zu weihnachten wieder
aufzumachen und zu lockern
weihnachten wird damit zu einem fest mit
einem todesrisiko für manche menschen
aber ich will darauf hinweisen dass es
zwar lockerungen gibt aber keine
vollständige lockerungen zu weihnachten
das ist ja nicht so sondern gelten nach
wie vor regelungen er ist ja vorhin auch
erläutert wurden auch begrenzungs
regelung dass man sich mit so vielen
leuten trifft auf so vielen haushalten
aber wir müssen darauf setzen dass wir
nicht sozusagen mit alarmistischen
nachrichten sondern mit klarer
aufklärung und mit dem vernünftigen
verhalten der bürgerinnen und bürger das
machen und alle umfragen zeigen die
meisten menschen in diesem land
verhalten sich unglaublich aufgeklärt
vernünftig solidarisch und anständig das
was wir da an demos erleben ist ja gott
sei dank eine absolute minderheit kritik
ist vollkommen in ordnung auch in der
demokratie von allen seiten
aber es geht jetzt darum dass wir in
diesem land dass vernünftige tun um
unsere angehörigen unserer eigene
gesundheit zu schützen und das land gut
durch dieses schwierige zeit zu führen
und da muss ich sagen bewährt sich auch
unser demokratisches system wenn wir das
mit anderen ländern auf der welt
vergleichen
was gibt's zu machen was halten sie von
der lockerung wenn die richtig zu
weihnachten zunächst einmal natürlich
freue ich mich weil ich in den
pastoralen tun von bundesminister
hubertus heil so sehr verinnerlicht dass
zur weihnachtszeit zunächst einmal muss
man die rechtslage beachten wie der ist
einheitlichkeit infektions rechtlich
geboten es gibt die gesetzeslage her
noch kann man unter infektionsschutz
rechtlichen überlegungen weihnachten
lockern wenn es sie habe es vorhin
zurecht angesprochen warum ist das
infektionsrisiko gibt das zu herrschen
ist dann spielt weihnachten keine rolle
genauso wenig viele sonntag montag
dienstag mittwoch donnerstag oder ein
arbeitsfreier tag
ich verstehe ja selbstverständlich dass
man menschen entgegenkommen will das ist
der grund warum schließlich holstein
keine weiteren lockerungen weihnachten
vorn wir haben seit mehreren monaten die
zehn personen regel die ändern wir nicht
weil wir kein infektionsrisiko haben
dass den bayern oder baden württembergs
entspricht aber es gibt auch keine
weiteren lockerungen zu weihnachten
obwohl wir das im zweifel auch könnten
gerade weil wir davon ausgehen dass das
infektionsgeschehen der kontrolle
gehalten werden muss auch in schleswig
holstein und darüber hinaus aber noch
einmal weder ist einheitlichkeit
infektions rechtlich ein kriterium
noch ist die frage des wochentages oder
des feiertages ein kriterium wenn man
eine pandemie wirksam bekämpfen insofern
ist das rechtlich wieder geboten doch
ist es sinnvoll aber menschlich
nachvollziehbar das war weihnachten
einfach mehr begegnungen zu lassen will
sinnvoll sagt herr kubicki herr lehmann
sehen sie es ist weihnachten grund um
lockerungen vorzunehmen für einen kurzen
zeitraum zumindest noch mal am ende des
tages ist es die privatsphäre und da der
staat auch grundgesetz rechtlich nichts
zu suchen deswegen den ersten lockdown
haben wir klar geschafft mit einem
appell und das brauchen wir jetzt auch
richtwerte sind in ordnung aber am ende
des tages kommt es auf jeden einzelnen
an die wir weihnachten überstehen aber
ganz am ende des tages dürfen wir uns
nicht nur auf weihnachten und silvester
fokussieren dann ist die enttäuschung im
januar groß was wir brauchen ist eine
langfriststrategie wenn er strickt und
andere virologen recht haben werden wir
länger mit diesem virus leben müssen
deswegen dürfen wir nicht nur den fokus
jetzt auf weihnachten und silvester
legen sondern wirklich über eine
langfriststrategie reden das beginnt bei
den schnelltests in den alten und
pflegeheimen und endet bei den schulen
oder der korona app darüber müssen wir
mindestens genauso reden wir jetzt über
kurzfristige taten lindemann hat
angesprochen möglicherweise reichen
appelle friedrich merz einer der
anwärter auf den cdu-vorsitz sieht das
ähnlich der sagt was hat denn der staat
dazu suchen da hat sich nicht
einzumischen wie ich mein weihnachten
verbringe und durchaus gibt es auch
unter den ministerpräsidenten schon den
einen oder anderen der gesagt hat
natürlich werden wir unterm christbaum
nicht kontrollieren
nicht an was man bei sich zu hause macht
aber ich kann auch nur sagen corona
macht eben auch vor weihnachten und
silvester nicht halt kein mensch wird
das nachzählen am heiligen abend unter
den christbaum aber an jede familie geht
die bitte reduziert die kontakte so weit
dass in den familiären rahmen passt also
der staat will sich eigentlich
einmischen tut es dann aber doch sagt
dann aber dafür verschließen wir die
augen davor hätten es appelle dann nicht
hätten die nicht gereicht wird verlockt
das hat was sie ihn gefragt haben keiner
von dem gesagt ich würde das nicht
kontrollieren das ist doch aber auch
vernünftig in der demokratie es gibt ja
die unverletzlichkeit der wohnung
darf ich ihnen das kurz verantwortlich
es geht um das prinzip der
verhältnismässigkeit stadt hat regeln
aufgestellt und die sind auch nötig um
die gesundheit von menschen zu schützen
aber die schönsten regeln nutzen sind
nicht wenn sich niemand dran hält
deshalb haben alle ministerpräsidenten
ich sage das ja auch und das sagt ja im
kern auch an kubicki und der lindemann
gesagt es geht jetzt um die
selbstverantwortung von bürgerinnen und
bürgern auch über die festtage sich an
regeln zu halten auch an beschränkungen
aber wir sind kein polizeistaat wir sind
eine demokratie und der demokratie gibt
es grundrechte und bürgerrechte die sind
jetzt zum teil was sich bitter finde aus
gründen der pandemie eingeschränkt aber
wir werden nicht wie in china
das ganze machen können wir sind keine
diktatur deshalb wird nicht zu hause
kontrolliert es geht darum dass die
menschen sich vernünftig und anständig
verhalten und da sehe ich überhaupt
keinen widerspruch zu dem was die
ministerpräsidenten darüber wenn der ein
oder andere entscheidet unsere familie
ist doch etwas größer wir feiern mit 15
dann ist das auch okay auch wenn die
regel 10 ist man die grundregeln gelten
wie gesagt ich habe nur darauf
hingewiesen dass jetzt nicht
irgendwelche ich sag jetzt mal
polizisten wohnungen durchsuchen werden
sondern es geht darum dass wir erst mal
auf die vernunft von menschen setzen
wir haben allerdings auch erlebt dass in
bestimmten bereichen zum beispiel ein
partygeschehen ist ausgeufert dass
menschen sich gar nicht mehr ein regeln
auch im öffentlichen raum gehalten
japan wird eingegriffen auch an einen
öffentlichen raum in jedem fall wenn es
zu massenansammlungen kommt die wir
regeln entsprechen
dann muss eingegriffen werden so ist
auch die rechtslage diesem punkt hier
ging es lediglich um die frage was ja
ganz lebenspraktisch nicht geht ob man
jede wohnung in deutschland kontrolliert
das ist weder rechtlich geboten
noch ist es sinnvoll sondern es geht
darum dass wir die akzeptanz in diesem
land haben nehmen wir darüber aufklären
worum es geht und es geht noch mal um
gesundheit um leben
auch darum dass dieses land langfristig
wirtschaftlich gut kommt durch diesen
winter kommt indem wir mithelfen das
pandemie geschehen alle miteinander
einzuheben dass kein pastor rollatoren
ist ein gebot der vernunft
herr kubicki das war ein hinweis auch
sie wahrscheinlich doch gleich noch mal
zu ihnen
was halten sie von diesen regeln nochmal
einerseits vorschreibt zehn personen
maximum aber wir kontrollieren es nicht
wir versuchen es dann doch mit dem
appell und hoffen auf den gesunden
menschenverstand
das waren wir ja grundsätzlich also auch
dort wo wir strafnormen haben ab jetzt
zunächst dass man eine gesunde
menschenverstand und sagen nur wenn das
nichts nützt dann werden menschen in
zwei verfolgt und auch verurteilt hier
handle sich aber immer um fragen des
ordnungswidrigkeitenrecht und
virtualität prinzip selbstverständlich
wird kein polizeibeamte heiligabend oder
silvester wenn elf leute in einer
wohnung sind die wohnung betreten und
einen aus der wohnung geleit und muskeln
verfahren einleiten was aber passieren
könnte ist das wenn es eine
weihnachtsparty geht mit 30 oder 40
leuten und die nachbarn melden dass die
polizei die bei der lärmbelästigung aber
vor ort steht und sagt die party ist zu
ende und die welt darum bitten oder wie
wir und darum bitten dass 20 leute das
ist jedoch des geschehens verlassen
weihnachten wird sie möglicherweise auch
das blatt im wind eine ermahnung
belassen aber es könnten auch ein ausweg
ein verfahren einleiten was dann zu
einem bußgeld führen können aber noch
einmal mein vertrauen in die menschen
dass sich weihnachten und auch aus dem
westen überwiegen auch aus eigenschutz
gründen vernünftig verhalten werden ist
relativ gross sieht das immer einen
sozialen umfeld und aus dem umfeld
meiner kinder die er immer noch
aufzuhalten partyszene gehören die
werden weihnachten im kleinsten unserem
kleinen familienkreis verbringen aber
noch einmal niemand muss angst haben den
staat 911 leute im raum sitzen wird
keiner kommen und den elften aus dem
haus gehalten
in belgien zumindest das vertrauen nicht
ganz so groß in die bürger denn in
belgien wird es auch weiterhin trotz
sinkender corona zahlen strikte kontakt
beschränkungen geben bis mitte januar
und zwar dürfen an weihnachten
beispielsweise haushalte nur eine
weitere person einladen alleinstehende
dürfen immerhin sich mit zwei freunden
oder verwandten treffen und die nachbarn
finden das auch nicht ganz so gut was
wir hier machen der gesundheitsminister
von belgien sagte diese woche wenn es
etwas gibt was das virus mag dann sind
das feste vor allem mit wechselnden
teilnehmern das müssen wir unbedingt
vermeiden deshalb finde ich dass unsere
nachbarländer nicht das tun was
angebracht wäre
herr linnemann ist das nicht der
konsequente kurs also bei den strikten
regeln zu bleiben auch über die
weihnachtsfeiertage
man muss sagen dass belgien eine ganz
andere situation hatte als 4
dort sind die kapazitäten in den
krankenhäusern zum teil an den grenzen
in deutschland ist das gott sei dank
noch nicht der fall
deswegen sind die beiden ländern nicht
zu vergleichen erste und der zweite
punkt ganz wichtig ich glaube ein grund
warum deutschland so gut im vergleich zu
vielen vielen anderen ländern vor allen
dingen anderen industrieländern durch
die krise kommt ist der umstand dass wir
uns an die regeln zum allergrößten teil
halten die eigenverantwortung in
deutschland wird groß geschrieben haben
dass beim ersten lockdown gesehen und
deswegen kann ich in diesem punkt herrn
heil und herrn kubicki ausdrücklich
zustimmen auf diese eigenverantwortlich
auf diese eigenverantwortung wird es
ankommen natürlich über die feiertage
mehr denn je mit am stärksten betroffen
in deutschland sind ja die hotels die
hotelbranche und die müssen auch bis auf
ein paar wenige ausnahmen jetzt an
weihnachten weiter geschlossen bleiben
zumindest hier in deutschland
anderenorts zum beispiel auf den kanaren
laden die hotelchefs durchaus deutsche
touristen ein
verreisen kurz vor den feiertagen was
sich in deutschland eher als problem
darstellt aufgrund der korona pandemie
scheint derzeit auf den kanarischen
inseln ausdrücklich erwünscht zu sein
wir haben im moment ist prozent
reserviert aber wir erwarten neue
reservierungen wie weihnachten und
silvester sind die besondere des tages
des jahres
silvester ist wie uns die wichtigste
dach des jahres und wenn ich sie dann
wieder eine gala buffet keine galadiner
und eine doppelpartie an alle zu hause
kommt auf die kanarischen inseln zum
urlaubmachen der sicherste ort europas
wir alle stehen hier spalier und
empfangen euch mit offenem herzen sei es
die restaurants die cafés die hotels
alles das was in deutschland momentan
nicht möglich ist hier bei uns auf den
inseln sei er an einem sicheren ort
das genaue gegenteil scharbeutz im süden
der lübecker bucht direkt neben dem
timmendorfer strand hier sieht das
strandleben er tagaus winterliche
temperaturen und kaum menschen an der
ostsee viele menschen und die
gastronomen kämpfen dort ums überleben
wegen ausbleiben der touristen
das trifft uns ganz erheblich denn das
ist hier an der küste immer noch also
gerade das silvesterfest ein zeitpunkt
in dem die normalerweise vollbelegung
haben was für uns das allerschlimmste
wäre wäre wenn die betriebe auf gehen
und zu gehen und auf gehen und zu gehen
weil das ist viel viel schlimmer noch
als wenn man eineinhalb monat länger zu
hat und dann sind die zahlen unten und
wir können uns auch darauf verlassen
dass wir geöffnet bleiben können aber wo
ich am meisten angst vor hab weil das
mit noch erheblichen kosten verbunden
wäre es ein schnelles öffnen mit einer
nochmaligen schließung werden wir
brauchen den vorlauf für buchungen und
zumindest eine prognose herr minister
wann dürfen wir wieder aufmachen dann
bereiten wir uns auch mit allen
sicherheitskonzepten gerne wieder auf
eine wiedereröffnung vor
herr minister sie haben es gehört die
letzte botschaft war direkt an sie
gerichtet wann darf die deutsche
hotelbesitzerin auch wieder aufmachen
ich würde ihn gerne ganz klar
dort geben aber es hängt ehrlich gesagt
vom infektionsgeschehen ab dass wir
immer mit den ländern zu besprechen
haben wie die zahlen sind das ist ja mal
ein bisschen zeit verzögert die
maßnahmen brauchen bis in der statistik
niederschlag finden
bis dahin helfen wir auch unternehmen
die unmittelbar betroffen sind vom lock
down mit jetzt.de november/dezember
hilfe mit übrigens auch der möglichkeit
von kurzarbeit dafür bin ich
verantwortlich
brücken zu bauen über ein tiefes
wirtschaftliches tal und ich kann die
sehnsucht nach planungssicherheit
verstehen deshalb hat er lehne man recht
wir brauchen langfristige strategien was
test kapazitäten betrifft beispielsweise
wir haben die hoffnung im nächsten jahr
auf den impfstoff jetzt müssen wir das
durch den nächsten wochen kommen wir
haben in teilen ein erhebliches
infektionsgeschehen ich will noch ein
satz dazu sagen weil mich das oft
erreicht ich kann die bitterkeit auch
vieler gastronomen verstehen oder auch
hoteliers die sagen haben endlich gute
hygiene konzept über uns haben sich
wenig oder niemand angesteckt aber darum
geht es leider im detail nicht sondern
es geht um die frage ob wir viele
soziale begegnungen haben und der preis
dass wir versuchen schulen offen zu
halten und andere orte wo sich sehr sehr
viele menschen treffen auch kitas ist
dass wir in anderen bereichen das hat
mit geselligkeit zu tun mit dingen die
wir eigentlich alle ganz gerne mögen
versucht haben dinge einzuschränken und
versuchen wie gesagt den unternehmen zu
helfen um durch diese schwierige zeit zu
kommen also ich kann jetzt nicht
prognostizieren
wie die infektionszahlen ich sag mal am
23 dezember sind sondern haben wir die
nachrichten des rk ii des robert koch
instituts und dann stehen auch
entscheidungen an wie es im januar
weitergeht ich hoffe darauf dass das
besser wird
das wäre ja nicht verantwortlich können
sie denn zumindest sagen wenn es
weitergeht wenn er noch dauern bis in
den märz reicht dass die
november/dezember hilfen dann auch im
januar februar märz gezahlt werden also
spekulieren nicht jetzt sozusagen auf
den dauerhaften lockdown sondern wir tun
ja alles um die zahlen so
runterzubringen das erste unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
und dann wenn wir es einigermaßen im
griff haben wenn kontakt nachverfolgung
wieder stattfinden kann
auch lockerungen anstatt zu bringen
niemand macht sich das ja leicht dass
dinge die uns lieb und wichtig sind
beschränkt sind
aber wir müssen abwägen wir müssen
güterabwägung und die güterabwägung ist
solange das infektionsgeschehen den
einzelnen landkreisen in vielen regionen
auch kaum mehr kontrollierbar ist
kontakt nachverfolgung nicht stattfinden
kann ist immer die gefahr dass das so
ansteigt dass das gesundheitswesen
überlastet wird da und solange das so
ist will ich nicht spekulieren es gibt
durchaus einige vertreter der regierung
die bereits spekulieren wir wollen
später noch einmal darauf schauen herr
altmaier herr braun auch aber zunächst
noch mal an sie die frage herr kubicki
wie viele jobs wie viele arbeitsplätze
kann dieser winter dieser corona winter
möglicherweise kosten wenn dann
irgendwann herauskommen also wenn ich
das genau wissen könnte dann würde ich
jetzt lotto spielen und dann sechs
richtige im lotto das kann man von uns
seriös beantworten aber es wird eine
menge arbeitsplätze kosten
die gastronomischen bereiche weiter der
bereich ich komme ja wie gesagt von der
küste und wir haben interessanterweise
in den küsten kreisen keine und
instanzen das bedeutet dass die hygiene
konzepte deckt der gastronomische
betriebe und die hoteliers gewirkt haben
gleichwohl laden sie und sind sie im
november geschlossen geblieben und
werden im dezember ausgeschlossen
bleiben
das ist auch nur zu rechtfertigen weil
sie entsprechende entschädigung der
staatsleistungen durch den staat
bekommen durch den bund regele liegende
zahl wenn sich der lockdown fortsetzen
sollte wird auch der bund nach wie vor
eintreten müssen das wird nicht zu
erklären seien
das sind 1 januar februar die hotels in
die gastronomische betriebe weiterhin
geschlossen erhält aber dann die
entschädigungs zahlungen ausbleiben
ja aber dann eben noch in einer ganzen
reihe von anderen bereichen erhebliche
probleme denn wenn kinder zu hause
bleiben müssen weil sie in quarantäne
müssen weil in der schule infektionen
aufgetreten sind haben die eltern keine
unterbringungsmöglichkeiten wenn ich
erlebe das bei mir in meinem eigenen
büro dass meine eigenen kanzlei dass
mitarbeiterinnen dann auch zu hause
bleiben müssen weil es ansonsten keine
betreuungsmöglichkeit für die kinder
gibt wir werden das erleben das mcm in
der modebranche
wir eine ganze reihe von geschäften
laden schließen müssen wir hören das
sind darüber wird diskutiert das ganze
hin steht daraus bluten weil menschen
nicht mehr linien steht der eben doch
nicht mehr einkaufen sondern sich über
amazon entdecken also ein das wird
folgewirkungen haben die werden wir aber
erst mitte nächsten jahres spüren und
bei aller wertschätzung auf das
bundesarbeitsministers oberto sei das
kurzarbeitergeld hilft ja nur wenn man
eine perspektive hat das aus der
kurzarbeit keine arbeitslosigkeit werden
musste weil man irgendwann mal wieder
umsatz macht wenn diese perspektive
nicht mehr da ist dann werden die
menschen entlassen werden und das wird
unser nächstes problem werden
ich bin gespannt wie wir insgesamt
gesellschaft damit fertig werden weil
wir neben diesen dingen auch die zunahme
von von selbstmorden haben die frage von
vereinsamung die tatsache dass
beispielsweise bei der darmkrebsvorsorge
wie ein rückgang von fast 100 prozent
auch das wird ja folgewirkungen haben
ich höre von freunden von mir bei der
uniklinik in kiel dass ein viertel der
herzinfarktpatienten gar nicht mehr
auftauchen die sich nicht von heute auf
morgen weg also auch diese
folgewirkungen werden wir beachten
müssen
das wird die gesellschaft noch sehr
massiv beschäftigen aber wir werden es
nur schaffen wenn die politik
überzeugende antworten gibt auch die
fragen die im raum stehen würde ich
gerne an sie weitergeben
herr kubicki hat angesprochen
kurzarbeitergeld bringt natürlich nur
was wenn man auch noch in kurzarbeit ist
aber wenn im nächsten jahr
möglicherweise eine pleitewelle droht
dann kann ein auch das kurzarbeitergeld
nicht mehr retten wie viele arbeitslose
erwarten sehr erwarten sie da ein
anstieg
also ich kann als arbeitsminister
tatsächlich in der tiefsten
wirtschaftskrise unseres landes unter
sich eine weltweite krise nicht über für
jeden einzelnen arbeitsplatz garantieren
aber wir werden um jeden kämpfen und das
kurzarbeitergeld ist eine wesentliche
brücke für die zeit wenn die unternehmen
wieder richtig los werden legen können
übrigens dann auch die fachkräfte an
bord zu haben und wir bauen diese brücke
wir haben das gerade beschlossene
verlängern das ins nächste jahr
das hilft übrigens auch
gesamtwirtschaftlich der nachfrage und
das will ich mal vergleichen mit anderen
ländern auf der welt ich will das mal
klar sagen wir sind in der tiefsten
wirtschaftskrise ist hat folgendes wird
auch unternehmenspleiten geben aber wir
werden so viel wie möglich substanz
sichern damit die wirtschaft wieder
durchstarten kann wenn es auch wieder
aufwärts geht in den usa sind bis zu 50
millionen jobs verschwunden in dieser
krise
in deutschland hatten wir auch ein
anstieg der arbeitslosigkeit aber
gemessen daran sichern wir mit der
kurzarbeit millionen von jobs leisten
hilfe für unternehmen im november und
dezember hilfe überbrückungshilfen um
dieses land auch wirtschaftlich und
sozial durch die krise zu bringen
das mal so sagen der zeit wo viele
menschen sich um ihre gesundheit angst
machen
so sorgen machen oder die gesundheit
ihrer angehörigen versuchen wir wo immer
es geht wirtschaftliche und soziale
sorgen den menschen von den schultern zu
nehmen und das geht nur mit einem
starken sozialstaat in hamm bilden man
sucht sich sicherlich bei ihnen im
ministerium auch bestens vorzubereiten
auf möglicherweise veränderungen der
arbeitslosenzahlen durch zeiten und so
weiter was ist da die prognose heute in
einem jahr mehr mehr arbeitslose als
jetzt wir werden wir haben jetzt
ungefähr eine halbe million mehr
arbeitslose als vor der krise
das ist wie gesagt für jeden einzelnen
schlimm aber verhältnis nicht zu dem was
für international erleben ich habe es ja
vorhin gesagt 50 millionen jobs in den
usa
wir können wir werden wahrscheinlich
jetzt erleben dass die arbeitslosigkeit
über den winter noch mal ein stück
steigt aber im verhältnis zu dem was wir
mit kurzarbeit sichert ist das relativ
wenig und auch die zahl der kurzarbeiter
wird nicht mehr so hoch sein wie man im
april da hatten wir sage und schreibe
sechs millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
jetzt sind viele gott sei dank auch
wieder in arbeit zurückgekehrt
würden sie sagen heute ich glaube dass
wir das vorkrisenniveau
wenn wir das infektionsgeschehen im
griff bekommen wenn wir international
nicht noch andere dinge erleben da sind
ja immer auch ein paar stellschrauben
die wir nicht in der hand haben und wenn
wir den impfstoff bekommen dann haben
wir die chance im jahr 2022 also im
übernächsten jahr wirtschaft wieder
licht wieder auf vorkrisenniveau zu sein
das heißt nicht dass in einzelnen
branchen durch radikale veränderungen
gibt aber das land hat alle chancen
durch diese schwierige zeit zu kommen
oder wie der bundespräsident ist heute
gesagt hat wir haben unsere zukunft vor
und sind wir lassen uns von diesem virus
auch die zukunft nicht kaputt machen
jemand der nicht ganz so optimistisch
ins nächste jahr schaut ist in die
bundesbank vize präsidentin claudia buch
sie warnte heute vor einer pleitewelle
konkret sagte sie die lage ist im moment
verzerrt insolvenzen tauchen erst in den
statistiken auf wenn verfahren
abgeschlossen sind aktuell sehen die
zahlen auf den ersten blick noch gut aus
aber nur weil viele verfahren
aufgeschoben werden so wird es nicht
bleiben und die sektoren werden
unterschiedlich stark betroffen sein
herr lindemann droht uns eine
pleitewelle wenn die insolvenzregeln
dann wieder gelten die droht nicht nur
die wird kommen
hubertus heil hat natürlich recht dass
das kurzarbeitergeld ein riesen
erfolgsmodell ist die welt beneidet uns
darum
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch dass
dieses jahr aufgelaufen das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
die weniger insolvenzen haben als im
letzten jahr
ohne corona das hängt mit dem umstand
zusammen dass firmen nicht zahlungsfähig
sind bis vor kurzem keine insolvenz
anmelden mussten
selbst firmen die überschuldet sind
müssen jetzt keine insolvenz anmelden
sondern erst ab dem 11 kommenden jahres
das heißt wir werden im ersten quartal
6000 7000 8000 insolvenzen er leben im
maschinenbau im automobilbereich aber
wahrscheinlich auch veranstaltungs
hotelbereich ich will ja nicht ins
detail gehen nur man muss diese wahrheit
auch aussprechen weil wenn wir jetzt
diesen insolvenzgrund überschuldung und
zahlungsunfähigkeit immer weiter
aussetzen dann verschlimmern wir ja das
problem weil es gibt beispielsweise
zulieferer die offene rechnung haben mit
anderen firmen
die würden wir ja dann mit in den
abgrund ziehen deswegen müssen sie uns
ehrlich machen und die insolvenzen
werden kommen ja aber dieses land ist
stark genug um das zu überstehen
der arbeitsmarkt übersteht dass das
arbeitsministerium das budget das
überstehen kann
es geht ja darum dass für diese krise
überstehen da wird es auch
arbeitslosigkeit geben ich habe darauf
hingewiesen
aber ich will alles tun dass die
rückkehr von massenarbeitslosigkeit
dauerhaft nicht mehr folgen dieser krise
ist und diese chance haben wir nicht nur
mit der kurzarbeit sondern weil wir in
bestimmten branchen in dem wir auch
erleben das ist ja nicht nur um die
konjunkturelle krise geht es in der
strukturwandel durch digitalisierung zum
beispiel sich in einzelnen bereichen
verändert
dafür sorgen müssen dass jetzt zum
beispiel kurzarbeit mit qualifizierung
verbinden damit die beschäftigten von
heute auch die chance haben die arbeit
von morgen zu machen also nochmal das
ist die tiefste wirtschaftskrise unserer
generation nicht vergleichbar mit der
finanz und wirtschaftskrise von vor zehn
jahren
aber wir haben die chance da wieder
rauszukommen und ich kämpfe dafür dass
massenarbeitslosigkeit keine dauer folge
dieser krise ist und die instrumente hat
unser staat mit der wirtschaft und den
gewerkschaften zusammen haben wir alle
chancen das besser zu überstehen als
alle anderen länder auf der welt herr
kubicki bislang hat die regierung ja
einiges ausgeglichen durch
milliardenzahlungen aber auch die
kanzlerin sagt jetzt schon das geht
nicht bis ultimo so weiter was glauben
sie denn wie lange können die korona
folgen noch ausgeglichen werden über den
staatshaushalt
bevor ich diese frage beantworte möchte
ich gerne etwas zu resolvenz sagen denn
offensichtlich scheint einige meiner
kollegin kollegen berlin nicht zu wissen
wie das insolvenzrecht funktioniert wenn
wir haben erst 2021 den insolvenzgrund
überschuldung haben werden viele
unternehmen insolvenzantrag stellen
müssen schon aufgrund der ihnen
gewährten hilfen die er überwiegend als
kredite ausgelegt worden sind der kfw
die kredite wenn sie keinen umsatz daran
verlängern die passig bilanz das
bedeutet sie sind schneller überschuldet
also wenn sie normalen geschäftsverkehr
unterwegs werden das wird eine menge
unternehmen treffen wenn die politik da
auch nicht schnell genug und angemessen
reagiert nun zu ihrer frage wie lange
kann der staat das durchhalten
theoretisch nahezu unendlich weil die
ezb will muss mit deutschland der lage
ist nicht zu verschulden auf teufel komm
raus das wird dann eine rechnung werden
die die künftige generation als die
generation meiner kinder und meiner
enkel bezahlen muss aber es wird zu
einer massiven verwerfungen innerhalb
der staatshaushalte von bund und ländern
führen die überlegung der kanzlerin die
länder sollten sich beteiligen
ist es aber etwas absurd weil die länder
anders als der bund ganz strikte
verschuldungsregeln haben im rahmen
verfassungsänderungen die bei der für
die kommission zwei umgesetzt worden
sind dass das land endlich vorstellen
kann sich nicht weiter verschulden als
es jetzt verschuldet hat das land bayern
möglicherweise schon das würde zu einer
unglaublichen unwucht führen im
föderalen system deshalb bin ich mir
sicher wenn weiter gewährleistet werden
und sie müssen weiter gewährt werden
dann kann das nur auf bundesebene
geschehen und mit den ländern einen
anderen verteilungsschlüssel finden muss
man sich ehrlich machen und sagen am
ende werden dann doch die steuern erhöht
dich wort corona soli der schon im
gespräch ist gerade bei der spd in ihrer
partei also erstmal werden zum ersten
januar was gesamtwirtschaftlich richtig
ist die steuern gesenkt der soli feld
für 90 prozent derjenigen weg die ihn
bisher bezahlt haben das stärkt auch die
nachfrage und ich will es mal ein
beispiel kurzarbeit machen kurzarbeit
ist zb sehr sehr teuer und wir kommen
jetzt auch nach diesem jahr ins nächste
jahr nicht mehr mit den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen da aus
obwohl wir rücklagen von 26 milliarden
euro hatten
deshalb werden wir nächstes jahr ein
bundeszuschuss aus dem bundeshaushalt
brauchen auch um die beiträge übrigens
stabil zu halten
und da gilt der grundsatz kurzarbeit ist
sehr sehr teuer massenarbeitslosigkeit
wäre für den staat und die gesellschaft
viel viel teurer wäre also falsch jetzt
in die krise rein zu sparen sondern wir
müssen diese brücken bauen um die
wirtschaftliche substanz zu erhalten
diesen land nach der krise auch wieder
durchstarten zu können ich will auch
keinen hinweis mehr erlauben
das ist total bitter nachdem wir jetzt
wirklich den bundeshaushalt den letzten
jahren ja wirklich richtig im griff
hatten durch eine gute wirtschaftliche
phase dass wir soviel jetzt auch
schulden machen müssen aber in der
gesamtschulden sfar quote quote unseres
staates sind wir unter der
verschuldungsquote der letzten krise der
finanzkrise und auch nach der
finanzkrise
das heißt es ist jetzt gut dass wir vor
der krise das geld zusammengehalten
haben damit wir jetzt gegen die krise
uns auch finanziell stemmen können und
das gilt für bund länder und kommunen
die kassen waren voll jetzt sind sie
leer jetzt muss schon müssen schon
mittel aus dem staatshaushalt über
geschoben werden wenn die beitrage
erträge nicht erhöht werden sollen dann
wird es am ende doch steuererhöhungen
geben
wir haben uns in der bundesregierung
verabredet dass wir in der krise die
leistung die sozialen leistungen zum
beispiel nicht kürzen und auch die
beiträge nicht erhöhen
das führt dazu dass wir einen zuschuss
beispielsweise an die
kasse haben um die zum beispiel die auch
krankenhäuser zu unterstützen
aus steuergeldern gleiches gilt für die
bundesagentur für arbeit danach wenn die
wirtschaft wieder in gang kommt dann
gibt es auch wieder einnahmen für den
staat sozialversicherungsbeiträge oder
steuereinnahmen und langfristig wird man
auch über die aufteilung von kosten in
der gesellschaft reden müssen
aber jetzt ist nicht die zeit darüber zu
spekulieren jetzt ist die zeit zu
handeln um deutschland erst durch diese
krise zu führen und mit der sozial
garantie haben wir gesagt in der krise
werden keine beiträge erhöht und es
werden auch keine sozialleistung gekürzt
darauf kann sich jeder verlassen hätte
man also in der krise soll nicht darüber
diskutiert werden und langfristig soll
dann aber doch über die kostenverteilung
gesprochen werden sagt minister hey wie
glaubwürdig ist es denn dass die steuern
nicht erhöht werden langfristig ich
halte von der debatte wirklich nichts
also ich bin fast ja muss man so sagen
eigentlich jeden tag mit der
intensivstation der deutschen wirtschaft
in kontakt des mittelstandes von
messebauer bis zu einem hotelier im
schwarzwald ein familienbetrieb über die
gesamte tourismusbranche bis hin zu
restaurants und hotels und wenn die so
eine debatte ran dann fragen die nicht
wirklich herr lindemann wo leben sie die
sind sozusagen auf dem boot unterwegs in
nebel wissen nicht wann das ufer kommen
wenn die pandemie besiegt es verbrennen
ihr eigenkapital wir reden über
zusätzliche belastungen
deswegen sollten wir das sie täglich
sein lassen und im nächsten
bundestagswahlkampf wenn es dann eine
debatte über steuererhöhungen gibt oder
was auch immer können gerne die parteien
darüber diskutieren völlig legitim aber
ich halte das zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht für richtig und übrigens im
bundestagswahlkampf auch nicht für meine
partei so richtig reinen wein wollte uns
die kanzlerin bisher ja nicht
einschränken wie lange der lockdown
strecke schrägstrich teilen lockdown
noch dauert sie appelliert immer wieder
daran dass wir alle viel geduld brauchen
und ja für diesen kurs und gibt es jetzt
durchaus schon kritik in den eigenen
reihen
wir brauchen noch einmal eine
kraftanstrengung geduld solidarität
disziplin werden noch einmal auf eine
harte probe gestellt beim frühjahrs wird
damit deutlich andere locker und knapp
mit schnell wirkende maßnahmen wir sehen
um uns herum länder wie frankreich oder
belgien die sehr harte den doktoren
einsteigen mit schnelleren erfolgen das
heißt es muss eben klar sein
der bewusste entscheidung weniger
gesellschaftliche folgen jetzt zu haben
bedeutet eine längere zeit die wir an
geduld aber trotzdem beschleicht mich
das gefühl dass diese maßnahmen nicht
ausreichen um wirklich nachhaltig diese
wette zu brechen und die zahlen nach
unten zu treiben
lass mich da gerne eines besseren
belehren ich persönlich sage mir ich
hätte mir gerne konsequenteren maßnahmen
gewünscht konsequentere maßnahmen weil
nämlich einst auch richtig ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dieses
scheibchenweise immer einen draufsetzen
das zermürbt uns doch alle
herr kubicki
was sagen sie zu dieser aussage hat er
recht das zermürbt uns alle jetzt
zunächst einmal finde ich es sehr
inspiriert ist der fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu csu fraktion im deutschen
bundestag der bundeskanzlerin in offener
debatte deutlich in zwei punkten
jedenfalls widerspricht nämlich dem
einen punkt dass er davon ausgeht dass
die maßnahmen nicht ausreichend werden
der zweite punkt dass eine
länderbeteiligung an die kosten wünscht
und nicht einfach die ministerpräsident
die kanzlerin darüber befinden können
was denn der bundesgesetzgeber der den
haushalt verabschieden muss einzustellen
hat ich glaube das was wir brauchen ist
planbarkeit und insofern teile ich die
auffassung von den kollegen trinkaus das
hat man ja auch schon gesagt dass wir
eine längerfristige strategie brauchen
mit dem virus zu leben ich vermute
persönlich auch dass wir trotz aller
hoffnung auf den impfstoff bis mitte des
jahres definitiv damit zu tun haben
werden die infektionszahlen der
einigermaßen im griff zu behalten und
das wird eine echte herausforderung
werden
bis dahin müssen wir sehen dass wir ein
vernünftiges leben wieder hinbekommen
planbarkeit uns auch für die unternehmen
stellen jetzt fest wie wichtig eine
funktionierende wirtschaft ist und
deshalb müssen wir uns darauf
konzentrieren dass die wirtschaft dass
er hier auch wieder funktionieren kann
dass alle maßnahmen unterbunden werden
die einen wiederaufleben der
wirtschaftlichen aktivitäten verhindert
und dass wir sozusagen den menschen
dabei helfen die der umsatz zu machen
das bruttoinlandsprodukt zu steigern
denn ich teile die auffassung des
sachverständigenrates für die
gesamtwirtschaftliche entwicklung dass
man mit einem vernünftigen wachstum
innerhalb von 10 15 jahren die schulden
jetzt aufgenommen werden auch wieder
zurückführen kann aus dem wachstum
heraus ohne dass wir steuererhöhungen
oder andere maßnahmen brauchen aber
dafür ist voraussetzung eine
funktionierende wirtschaft die braucht
planbarkeit die braucht tatsächlich
einen längerfristigen atem denn wie die
gastronomin aus deutschland gesagt hat
für zwei tage auf machen wieder zu
machen das verwirrt nicht nur sein dass
auch wirtschaftlich unsinnig hohe kosten
beinhaltet ohne die entsprechende
umsätze generieren zu können
planbarkeit ist wichtig das heißt auch
sich zu konzentrieren auf die wilderei
in gruppen schließlich otter ist deshalb
so gut auch der vorfälle sehr früh mit
sp2 massen gearbeitet haben in alten und
pflegeheimen weil wir sehr schnell auch
das gestellt haben das ist wichtig ist
die beschäftigten in alten pflegeheimen
zu testen da muss es keine kontakt
beschränkungen geben sondern einfach nur
eigenschutz ich plädiere seit mai immer
wieder nicht mit alltags massen
rumzulaufen mit sp2 masken weil die auf
einen eigenschutz beinhalten und damit
das infektionsrisiko wirklich drastisch
reduzieren
diese botschaft mit ffp zwei monaten
auch angekommen aber auch planbarkeit
und perspektive was immer wieder
angemahnt wird es gibt einige wenige
auch regierungsmitglieder die bereits
eine prognose wagen einer davon ist
merkels kanzleramtschef helge braun er
sprach diese woche davon dass es
möglicherweise bis märz geht vor uns
liegen schwierige wintermonate das geht
bis märz die kanzlerin wagt noch keine
prognose hier nochmal ihre chance würden
sie
so weit gehen und sagen der teil
lockdown geht auf jeden fall in den ins
frühjahr hinein einfach nur damit
beispielsweise hoteliers wissen wir
können erst mal die nächsten wochen noch
geschlossen haben ich kann das nicht
ausschließen es hängt vom
infektionsgeschehen ab aber ich will auf
1 hinweisen weil wir ja bei aller härte
für gastronomen und veranstaltungen und
vieles andere darauf hinweisen müssen
wir haben keinen lockdown der wirtschaft
also produktion zb in deutschland
handwerk herstellen von dingen ist nicht
von staatlichen maßnahmen beschränkt
gleiches gilt übrigens weitestgehend für
den handel und wir versuchen kitas und
schulen offen zu halten
das heißt es ist nicht das gesamte
wirtschaftsleben wie wir das am lockdown
am anfang des jahres in spanien oder
italien erlebt haben die dargelegt dass
muss man immer auch noch sagen
also wenn es gelingt tatsächlich das
infektionsgeschehen griff zu bekommen
sind lockerungen dann auch möglich aber
das heißt die kontakt nachverfolgung
muss wieder möglich sein das kann bis
märz dauern es hängt jetzt von der frage
ab ob wir die zahlen nicht nur
stabilisieren das haben wir die
maßnahmen schon ergeben das ist kein
exponentielles wachstum gibt aber wir
sind auf viel zu hohen niveau
und wenn das so weitergeht ist das
gefährlich für die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems wenn wir es runter
bringen und dann einigermaßen griff
behalten wir immer noch einschränkungen
haben masken tragen abstand und vieles
andere mehr
und ich bin auch bei der frage
langfristiger strategie wir haben eine
riesen chancen da müssen wir ran
diese antigene schnelltests wie wir
haben die jetzt massiv mehr zur
verfügung stehen
die können auch helfen auch wenn die
teilöffnung machen dinge im griff zu
behalten
aber dafür müssen wir genug verfügbar
haben und die auch einsetzen am ende ist
da ich möchte genau an dieser stelle
jemanden in die diskussion holen der
nämlich genau glaubt dass wir gerade
nicht den richtigen weg geht gehen und
das ist wie er möglicherweise so schnell
die zahlen auch nicht verbessern
das ist medizin professoren auch
langjähriger regierungsberater professor
matthias schrappe
schönen guten abend herr professor
vielen dank dass sich zeit genommen
haben
was glauben sie wie lange wird dieser
lockdown denn wenn er unter diesen
vorzeichen so fortgesetzt wird noch
andauern
naja
obwohl sie später am abend ist habe ich
immer noch keine seherischen fähigkeiten
entwickelt am ersten advent wir in
unsere arbeitsgruppe die jetzt mehrere
papiere veröffentlicht hat zu der
thematik haben schon im april gesagt das
problem wenn man einseitig auf locker
und setzt ist das wenn zweimal zu
funktionieren scheint scheint dass man
nie damit aufhören kann
und insofern kommt für uns auch die
jetzige situation alles andere als
überraschend wir haben es auch immer im
oktober klar vorhergesagt dass man jetzt
zu 1
ja so ein halt vor sich hin rücken hat
das liegt daran dass man das zweite bein
jeglicher vernünftiger präventions-
anstrengungen in deutschland missachtet
hat nämlich einen noch viel aktiveren
schutz der wohngruppen weit über das
verteilen von fb zwei masken hinausgehen
sie waren ja vor einem endlos lockdown
eben gerade weil man zu sehr nur auf die
inzidenz zahl 50 pro hunderttausend
blick können sie das noch mal erläutern
na gut das sind zwei dinge nicht endlos
lockdown kommt dann zustande wenn man
ich sag mal den erfindungsreichtum
unserer gesellschaft diejenigen die
geschützt werden müssen diejenigen die
auf den rennsieg stationen liegen und
das höchste risiko zu sterben oder
schwere komplikationen zu bekommen wenn
man dieses nicht fördert und das ist
immer abgelehnt worden obwohl wir das
bereits im april und andere personen die
davon etwas verstehen ja auch deutlich
gesagt haben
also ist das eine das andere ist wenn
man mit diesem nur bedingt tauglichen
lockdown mit
wenn es alleine eingesetzt wird arbeiten
möchte dann noch mit zahlen mit
grenzwerten das beurteilen möchte die
und das haben wir ja immer wieder
dargelegt selbst als zahlen nicht viel
tauben dann hat man zwei schwierigkeiten
erstens das schiff auf dem man fährt
kubicki hat es glaube ich eben genannt
das schiff auf dem man fährt hat ein
schweres lag weil es fehlt ein teil der
der vorgehensweise und man hat auch
überhaupt keinen kompass weil die zahlen
leider nichts taugen so wie sie bei uns
in deutschland erhoben werden vielen
dank herr professor schreibt affäre zeit
am sonntagabend
ich möchte das gerne noch mal an sie
weitergeben als regierungsvertreter
bedingt wirksames mittel haben wir
gerade gehört sollten wir mit dem
lockdown aufhören wir dürfen das
eigentlich gegen das andere stellen muss
das ja mal übersetzen wollen ihre
gruppen sind menschen die besonders
gefährdet sind
das sind aber ungefähr 27 millionen
menschen in deutschland ist ja nicht nur
ältere sondern auch vor erkrankte an
dieser stelle und man kann nicht 27
millionen menschen in einer gesellschaft
von 80 millionen absolut isolieren aber
muss gleichzeitig mehr tun da bin ich
bei dem experten um diese gruppen zu
schützen mit masken nicht nur in der
ausstattung an diesem punkt mit tests
beispielsweise dir jetzt auch an den
start kommen vor allen dingen auch in
alten- und pflegeheimen wird hinzufügen
einrichtung der behindertenhilfe und
gleichzeitig müssen wir tatsächlich das
pandemie geschehen durch begrenzung auch
von kontakten der gesamtgesellschaft
machen man kann diese einrichtungen
das haben wir leider erlebt auch nicht
so abschirmen dass das nicht auch über
greift also beides ist notwendig und
kein gegensatz zu den experten bei
einsatz
wir hören unglaublich viel auf experten
das ist auch vernünftig dass wir auf
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse setzen
aber eine eindeutige aussagen aus der
wissenschaft haben wir auch nicht wir
vorhin von der lindemann zitiert der
strick zum beispiel hat ja im frühjahr
noch über herdenimmunität spekuliert
wenn man darauf gesetzt hätten wie in
anderen ländern
dann wären wir richtig in einer ganz
schwierigen situation das heißt wir
müssen verschiedene stimmen aus der
wissenschaft zusammenfügen und es gibt
auch keinen plan und keine blaupause für
eine solche situation
sondern wir müssen auf basis von
wissenschaftlichen informationen die
richtigen schlüsse machen und mein
schluss ist die mischung von begrenzung
von kontakten unter schutz gefährdeter
gruppen sind kein widerspruch an beiden
muss man arbeiten ich möchte jetzt
zuletzt auf ein schönes thema kaum auf
das skifahren wobei uns in diesem in
dieser saison möglicherweise auch das
vergnügen daran genommen wird denn der
skiurlaub ist zum politikum geworden
am besten sollte der winterurlaub
verboten werden europaweit wenn es nach
der kanzlerin angela merkel und dem
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder geht doch weil die österreicher
beispielsweise nicht mitmachen wollen
hat söder jetzt die regeln verschärft
wer nach österreich dann in urlaub
fahren würde ist ein risikogebiet muss
zehn tage danach in quarantäne gehen und
muss bekommt keinen verdienstausfall
mehr entschädigt das ist das neue gesetz
des bundes und wir haben wir dann immer
klargemacht das gilt nicht nur für
längere reisen sondern auch für
tagesausflüge oder tagesausflüge nur zu
einem schreckgespenst löst dann auch die
entsprechenden einreise
quarantänevorschriften aus wir sprechen
gleich nochmal darüber wie
verhältnismäßig diese neue regel ist die
schweizer sind auf der zinne und wütend
auf die kanzlerin weil die deutschen
ihren urlaub bereits stornieren der
blick titelte heute frau merkel bei uns
sind sie sicher und schreibt dass die
menschen empört seien auch in engadin wo
durchaus auch die kanzlerin gerne mal
ihre winterferien verbringt und über
diese thematik wollen wir jetzt sprechen
mit der bergsteiger legende reinhold
messner herzlich willkommen herr messner
haben die schweizer und die österreicher
recht dass sie wütend auf die kanzlerin
also jetzt gar keine notwendigkeiten zu
sagen es ist traurig dass wir nicht in
europa in der lage sind gemeinsam über
die grenzen hinweg virus kennt ja auch
keine grenzen regeln in diesem
zusammenhang aufzustellen und das ist
eben wieder zu diesem krieg unter
anführungszeichen kommt wenn der
österreicher aus machen dann machen die
bayern entgegen projekte die schweizer
schon den lippen auch zu machen versucht
man die
die größten oder die gäste im inland zu
halten
ich bin der meinung dass das skifahren
so wie es im letzten frühling mit ein
paar hotspots in österreich war
ungerechterweise in die kritik
wenn man das skifahren reduziert wenn
man im winter den menschen nicht nur ski
pisten und seilbahnen anbietet sondern
auch wanderwege und rodelbahnen und
schlittschuhe möglichkeiten die menschen
wollten nach dieser krise die immer noch
vorteile und vielleicht auch noch länger
vortag auch zwischendurch einmal drei
räume erleben in ulm hinaus in dem
winter schnee natürlich ist das schiff
auf der piste gefährlich im anhang
mikrofone weil dort die menschen in
gruppen zusammenkommen
es ist sowieso eine peinlichkeit was bei
diesem après ski situationen passiert
sollte man für alle zeiten hinterfragen
aber ich möchte endlich dass diese alten
der erholungsraum in europa weit genutzt
werden auch dass die menschen sich in
familien schon denken oder in kleinen
freundes boden verlieren in den bergen
und damit die ansteckungsgefahr viel
geringer ist als in den bussen in den
städten in den städten generell bei der
weihnachtsfeier oder wo auch immer aber
muss außer stehen dass die menschen ein
recht haben jetzt eine erholungswoche
vielleicht einzulegen nun wenn
weihnachten und neuer ausfällt dann
haben die kinder nicht die möglichkeit
seine weihnachtsferien zu haben oder war
ja als trainer zu haben
wir werden dann im winter vielleicht
verein haben da wird wieder
wahrscheinlich überall oder fast überall
lockten sein aber mir wirklich nicht
gefällt ist diese kleinkarierte art und
weise da die touristen zurück zu halten
da sie anzulocken und mit diesen
vorschlägen wirtschaftliche vorteile zu
erwarten wir südtiroler sind ein rein
das touristenland wir sind vom tourismus
abhängig natürlich denkt die regeln
wichtig um so landeshauptmann hat eine
allgemeine situation herbeigeführt zwei
drittel davon haben sie testen
lassen die zahlen gehen langsam zurück
in einer woche können wir sagen ob die
zahlen so radikal zurückgegangen sind
dass wir um weihnachten südtiroler als
tourismusland anbieten könnten
aber wir werden uns seien verständlich
an der allgemeinen belgien halten die
europäisch festgelegt werden sollten und
nicht weiter regeln was ist denn ihrer
meinung nach richtig überall öffnen
skifahren erlauben après ski verbieten
beispielsweise ich muss nicht ganz
europa sein aber die länder die an den
alpen anteil haben bayern österreich
italien verwalten nicht rote zone
natürlich auch die schweiz gehört nicht
zur eu wenn man in den alpenländern eine
gemeinsame haltung
natürlich muss jeder geprüft werden muss
einen test machen
natürlich gelten die regeln die man
schon im sommer erarbeitet hat nur zwei
menschen an einem tisch und und und und
aggressiv verbieten und in den meisten
regionen sollten nicht einmal die hälfte
der menschen auftauchen die
normalerweise da sind das ist alles noch
verträglich aber vor allem den
wintersport nicht nur als skisport 7
sondern die wintersport möglichkeit vor
allem als erholung zu sehen stille weite
einsamkeit und vor allem schnee hält der
frische luft ja gute luft mirjam alkohol
und schließe mich kreuzigen
ministerpräsident söder unrecht wenn er
sagt dass man das skifahren nicht vom
après ski trennen kann
ich glaube das ist relativ gut brennbare
weil das ja lokale unternehmer sind in
diesem jahr
dadurch gehe unten aber bald bahn also
diese adresse situationen sind gleich ob
bei der unternehmer das einfach nicht
auswerten so wie heute bei uns es wurden
ja durchaus auch schon viele hygiene
konzepte erstellt kann man sagen dass
eine gondelfahrt mit hygiene konzept
gefährlicher ist als beispielsweise die
s bahn in münchen die noch erlaubt dass
das gefährlich ist ist natürlich eine
große zeit beim kantine mit 1000 leuten
1000 leuten ist ja wirklich hinter
trennen muss ich mal erzählen also 105
vielleicht auch ich habe noch nie
die hygiene konzepte also da machen der
fan schneider ja werbung dass sie das
begrenzen dass die gondel häufiger fährt
und dass wegen nicht mehr so voll ist
und ein skilift oder ein sessellift mit
vier plätzen zweimal gesetz das sind
dann entdecken oder ein skilehrer mit
einem gast da ist die ansteckungsgefahr
viel geringer als immer gleichen zeit
unter stadt also im gebirge den pta
deswegen unterwegs sein bis dorthin
gehen wo die meisten einfach nicht sind
weil wir uns verlieren können
die gäste haben platz wenn sie sich in
der landschaft verlieren und das ende
ich nicht nur jetzt in der korona krise
das eigentlich schon sehr lange
leider ist das eben selbst noch nicht
geschult er kommt in die alpen um diese
hohe die haben halt die stille zu
genießen und kommt dann und geht dorthin
wo alle anderen sind und deutschland
legal ist und dort entsteht dann hektik
inflation unruhe verbaute landschaft
genau das gegenteil von dem wasser
gesucht
auf jeden fall verbieten will ist die
kanzlerin die sie gut kennen konnten sie
dann mit ihr bereits darüber sprechen
also ich nicht doch da hatten die
kanzlerin im jahr haben wir das ganz
land beim ball unterwegs und sie genau
dort wo sie alles ja als berg mensch in
game will
in die einsamkeit sie bilden nicht mit
vielen menschen band und sie will
schließlich allein den berg hoch steigen
ja es ist auch nicht gern wenn jemand
hinter oder vor dir geht sondern sie
geht in ihrem schritt wie es ihre
kondition erlaubt sagt er wenn die zeit
zum trainieren in die berge und wenn sie
vorschläge machen sollte dass man die
berge anders aussucht alles eben mit
diesem extrem konzentrierten ski fahren
dann ist sie die richtige sie meisters
aber das ist jetzt natürlich eine
negative stimme gegen das schiff am
ausspricht nicht nachvollziehbar weiß
natürlich dass im kopf hat was ihm
wichtig im frühwinter passiert ist aber
eine frage noch wenn die kanzlerin sie
jetzt anrief und sagen würden mensch der
sebastian kurz will unbedingt aufmachen
der sola beschließen was soll ich denn
machen was ist richtig was würden sie
sagen
da würde ich sagen da kann es doch den
versuchen sie die beiden einigermaßen
wieder in frieden miteinander reden zu
lassen
in dem überall geöffnet werden darf
nein nicht über geöffnet werden aber wir
müssen auch das ganze als einen teil
unserer kultur ansehen dieses skifahren
gibt es seit etwa ja nicht ganz 100 er
vorher gab es das nicht man ist so ja
nur ins gebirge hineingegangen und jeder
oder jede ba für sich allein in kleine
töpfchen dann entstand eben doch die
seilbahnwirtschaft doch die pisten
präparierung dieser massen schiller und
alles andere würde vergessen wie jetzt
geht das schief anja zurück weil das
ganze feier geworden dazu viele familien
können sich das nicht mehr leisten
das beste fifa nimmt ab dass durstig
fahren nimmt zu verlieren sich die leute
unserer landschaft wenn das land aus
leidenschaft der kanzlerin ist gut
verträglich
aber viel wichtiger ist es dass ich auch
ohne irgendwelche gerätschaften einfach
mit einem kleinen rucksack und normalen
bergschuhen im winter wie ich jetzt
heute getan habe ich war auf zweieinhalb
tausend metern schnee unter dem motto
und habe einfach diese einsamkeit
genossen und habe innerhalb eines ganzen
tages einen einzigen menschen getragen
eine jäger redemption büro
und den habe ich im berühmten
respektsabstand nicht links liegen
gelassen mit dem ein paar worte
gewechselt und dann bin ich weiter
gesprungen
also es ist es gibt keine mancher besser
ist mit der korona krise zurechtzukommen
als das gebirge aber nicht mit der
methode werden bisher gewusst haben
vielleicht sagen sie dass der kanzlerin
dann doch noch mal persönlich
möglicherweise können sie sie umstimmen
vielen dank für ihre zeit an sie
weitergegeben herr minister wo stimmen
sie der kanzlerin zu ist das richtig zu
sagen skigebiete dicht und das am besten
europaweit oder würden sie sagen erstens
kann jedes andere jedes land das für
sich entscheiden und außerdem ist das
skifahren jetzt wirklich nicht die große
gefahr ich kann erst mal diese sehnsucht
sozusagen frei räumen die herr messner
auch beschrieben hat verstehen war auch
bei ihm in der nähe in der nähe von
sölden in trafoi auch schon mal und
skilaufen und rodel mit meinen kindern
ist eine super sache
aber es geht ja nicht nur um die hygiene
konzepte und es ist ja leider nicht
immer so wie er beschrieben hat das denn
alles im rucksack einzelnen wald haben
sondern es geht um die frage wie viel
menschen stoßen zusammen übrigens was
hätte italien südtirol oder österreich
davon wenn zum beispiel aus deutschen
hotspots menschen kämen wie wir das
umgekehrt aus im spiel erlebt haben und
wir massen infektionen haben
deshalb kann ich sozusagen die
zurückhaltende haltung der kanzlerin
verstehen und ich würde mir das wünschen
was reinhold messner gesagt hat nämlich
dass wir uns in europa dazu klar
abstimmen wir haben uns ja vorher ein
bisschen schockiert über leichte
unterschiede zwischen deutschen
bundesländern
es ist nicht gut dass wir in europa so
abgestimmt sind
darüber müssen wir reden wir müssen alle
vernünftig sein dass die italienische
regierung beispielsweise
gesprächsbereiter als er kurz ich hoffe
dass wir dazu gemeinsam lösungen kommen
wir müssen gemeinsam durch diesen winter
und ganz europa die ganze welt hat mit
dieser pandemie zu tun und deshalb er in
der abwägung zurückhaltung oder öffnen
bin ich dafür zurückhaltung und dann
eben auch mal auf den ski urlaub
verzichten da kann auch jeder selbst zu
beitrag ganz klar skifahren verbieten am
besten überall in europa ich würde in
diesem sommer erst mal individuell mit
meiner familie das nicht machen und ich
finde es richtig wenn wir an diesem
punkt uns konzentrieren und nicht so
viel reisen auch wenn es was erlaubt
sein sollte nicht so viel reisen weil
das tatsächlich soziale kontakte
ausbreitet und einem virus kreise
unterstützen sie den kurs dass die
kanzlerin sagt wir wollen zumindest mit
dem österreichischen kollegen reden was
sollten wir tun sonst gilt das ist gar
keine verschärfung was er da gesagt hat
dass aus risikogebieten wieder einreisen
auch zur quarantäne führt dass muss auch
jeder wissen so ist jetzt hier schon ein
paar mal gefallen herr kubicki sie
schütteln den kopf ist es denn gerecht
dass ich gehe immer wieder als maßstab
herangezogen wird wenn es ums skifahren
geht und was sagen sie sollten die
pisten geöffnet werden in dieser
besorgte zunächst einmal verstehe ich
hier die österreicher und die schweizer
die es als unglaublich anpassung
empfinden dass ausgerechnet deutsche
bundeskanzlerin ihnen erklärt wie sie
ihr leben in ihrem eigenen land
organisieren sollen selbstverständlich
kann bayern seine pisten schließen wenn
sie glauben das ist vernünftig ich
glaube das nicht skilaufen an sich ist
eine sportart die in freien stattfindet
und die auch im winter wenn man sonne
hat dazu beiträgt dass man seinen
vitamin d haushalt wieder aufbereiten
kennen das problem sind die après ski
veranstaltungen an denen ich früher als
ich noch jünger war auch zeigen normal
ich bin 30 jahre lang nach kiel gefahren
zum china überlegen dieses jahr nicht
ich bedauere das sehr
weil die gesagt der skilauf man sich
eine ganz vernünftige geschichte ist
dabei wenn man sich darauf konzentrieren
würde die après ski veranstaltung zu
unterbinden wenn man sich darauf
konzentrieren würde auf den hütten auch
die zugangsregelungen wie bei normalen
gastronomischen betrieben zu
organisieren dass also nur
einzelpersonen eintreten können und
wieder rausgehen können dann glaube ich
dass das infektionsrisiko
vergleichsweise gering ist auf der piste
genauso wie das infektionsrisiko bei
segelveranstaltung vergleichsweise
gering ist weil die menschen einer
frischen luft sind wollen sich die jury
nicht verbreiten können aber das ist
nicht nur ein problem mein problem ist
momentan dass wir diese form der
anmaßung an am deutschen wesen soll der
rest der welt genesen wieder erhebliche
probleme innerhalb europas bekommen
werden wir sollten zunächst unsere
eigenen hausaufgaben machen und die
anderen ihre hausaufgaben machen lassen
die schweiz steht beispielsweise nicht
schlechter da als ihr insofern wage ich
zu bezweifeln dass der rat aus
deutschland in der schweiz auf gehör
finden wird
und ich kann den appell von hubertus
heil unterstützen ich habe dies ja auch
verzichtet auf skiurlaub hätte ich auch
gemacht wird wenn der schiri hätte
stattfinden können ich werde auch im
frühjahr nicht skilaufen dieses jahr
oder im nächsten jahr nicht aus wie
gesagt aus eigentlich überlegung heraus
und das muss dann im zweifel für die
selbst entscheiden der infektionsschutz
muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
jeder ist für seine gesundheit selbst
verantwortlich und dieser appell muss in
der wieder wiederholte anmaßen stichwort
hat herr kubicki nicht recht
also erstens schätze ich wolfgang
kubicki sehr und wenn das alles mal
vorbei ist würde ich gern mit ihm auf
einer hütte auch mal einen trinken
aber er hat ja recht ist sozusagen das
dass wir neben carsten linnemann auch
mit den punkte sonst so traurig da nie
ganz ernsthaft es geht jetzt um eins um
eigenverantwortung es eben beschrieben
worden
aber auch die frage ob wir zu
touristischen reisen anreizen und da hat
wolfgang kubicki recht wir müssen in
deutschland unsere hausaufgaben machen
aber wir müssen europa auch darüber
reden was reisebewegungen touristische
reise bewegung für ein
infektionsgeschehen wir hatten können da
geht es nicht um anmaßungen sondern um
absprachen mit nein ich habe vorhin
gesagt ich würde mich würd mir wünschen
dass das sozusagen auch gelingt das ist
nicht ganz leicht aber bis dahin wenn
die einen das offenhalten und wie das
dichtmachen das hat ja wolfgang kubicki
mit hamburg vorhin beschrieben in
hamburg die gaststätten dicht macht und
die hotels und schleswig-holstein offen
lässt dann gehen die hamburger nach
schleswig-holstein das hat folgen für
das geschehen hatten auf die kanaren
dürfen die deutschen dann aber oder
werden sie auch entsprechend auf die
spanier ein weil ich würde jedem im
moment sagen überlegt hier gut ob du
reist so schön das ist aber das ding
hier ist ernst das ist kona das kein
spaß und wenn man erlebt hat was das mit
menschen macht auch an spätfolgen zum
teil und das für todesraten pro tag
haben die angst sind da sollte jeder
vorsichtig sein nicht alles was erlaubt
es sollte man auch machen aber mit der
spanischen regierung wird noch nicht
gesprochen
wir haben tatsächlich im moment auch
keine touristischen reisen auf der
spanische festland weil es ist ein
risiko oder auf den kanaren das ist so
an der stelle und wir waren auch nicht
vor regionen auf der welt das ist nicht
verboten aber man sollte sich trotzdem
trotz der netten appelle wie wir wollen
haben wirklich gut überlegen weil was
nützt den kanaren übrigens wenn wir zum
beispiel aus deutschland ein massives
infektionsgeschehen auf die kanal tragen
und die dann auch wieder locker machen
müssen
vielleicht mal eine zeit lang verzichten
um dann miteinander durchzuatmen
nächstes jahr gibt es doch die chance
auf dem impfstoff das wird ein bisschen
dauern
wir haben die chance zur lockerung wir
haben die chance durchzukommen
aber wir müssen durch diesen winter
gemeinschaftlich durch und da ist
vernunft vorsicht und verantwortung das
wesentliche geburt herr lindemann jetzt
haben wir hier beide meinungen vertreten
einerseits dem herrn kubicki der sagt
das sollte möglich sein ohne apres ski
aber die ansteckungsgefahr auf der piste
ist sicherlich nicht so akut dass man es
verbieten soll geschweige denn den
nachbarn vorschreiben soll ob sie öffnen
dürfen oder nicht wo ich den sie je
finden sie es richtig dass die kanzlerin
versucht da eine europaweite
einheitliche regelung zu finden oder
sagen sie wir sollten einfach die ski
pisten wenigstens ein bisschen spaß zu
lassen und öffnen
also erstens bedanke ich mich bei anhalt
für die einladung dass wir mal zusammen
auf die hütte gehen wenn die sonne
wieder scheint um die die pandemie
überstandener am zweitens habe ich in
meinem leben wie wir fußball gespielt
als die ski ausgesucht und ski gefahren
und drittens bin ich dabei der kanzlerin
in diesem punkt das virus kennt keine
grenzüberschreitung beziehungsweise
ascend grenzüberschreitung also es also
jede gleiche tätigkeit muss auch mit
gleichen regeln bedacht werden das heißt
mit anderen worten wir brauchen eine
europäische lösung man muss sich
gemeinsam an den tisch setzen und
überlegen wie gehen bevor und wenn die
zahlen in den nächsten wochen singen
dann könnte man sich vielleicht etwas
vorstellen das ganze unter ziemlich
strengen bedingungen so wie es auch
meine vorredner geschrieben haben oder
zumindest herr kubicki darüber
nachdenken wo man es unter strengen
bedingungen gestattet eine ganz schnelle
schlussrunde natürlich wollen wir diese
sendung nicht beenden ohne einmal kurz
über das impfen gesprochen zu haben sie
haben einmal freuen angesprochen aber
markus blume zu blume csu
generalsekretär
hält das impfen sogar für eine
patriotische pflicht stimmen sitzung wie
so pathetisch muss man nicht sein
es wird keine impfpflicht geben keine
gesetzliche aber ich setze auf die
vernunft und auch die sorge von menschen
also ja wenn impfstoff dass ich werde
mich impfen lassen aber zuerst übrigens
werden mal die im gesundheitswesen
geimpft dann die variablen gruppen
werden eher problem damit haben dass
mehr sich schneller impfen lassen wollen
als der wirkstoff und auch die technik
ist zulässt deshalb wir müssen da
solidarisch sein
aber wir müssen es auch hinbekommen dass
die vernunft zielt und die heißt wir
müssen das virus am ende mit dem
impfstoff besiegen
herr kubicki kämpfen als patriotische
pflicht
das ist quatsch diese rechte pathetische
äußerungen sind einfach nur unsinnig
selbstverständlich sollten wir dazu
auffordern zu impfen
bis man sich impfen lassen ich werde
mich impfen lassen wie bei der grippe
auch schon ich gehöre auch altersbedingt
schon zu niveau in arabien gruppen aber
nicht der seite soll ich finde es
vernünftig dass man auch wieder aus
eigenschutz heraus das risiko für sich
selbst so weit wie möglich minimiert der
länder man beim thema patriotische
pflicht würden mir als erstes glaube ich
auch andere dinge einfallen aber am ende
des tages geht es auch hier um
eigenverantwortung ich persönlich werde
mich auch in verlassen ich hatte mich
auch gegen die grippe geimpft aber er
hat etwas ganz wichtiges ausgesprochen
weil im gesamtnetz der politik
unterstellt wird dass es eine
impfpflicht eine zwangsimpfung gibt
dieses wird nicht kommen und heil ist
regierungsmitglied ich gehöre der
koalitionsfraktionen cdu/csu und dafür
kann nicht aussprechen insofern ist das
schön dass man das am ende dieser
sendung noch mal ziemlich klar stellt
damit wir vielleicht in den nächsten
tagen in bezug auf dieses thema
zwangsimpfung weniger mails bekommen und
eine letzte frage geht noch an herrn
kubicki denn sie waren in dieser woche
im bundestag bei einer weihnachtsbaum
übergabe der besonderen art kann man
sagen dabei geschmückt war dieser schöne
baum mit corona kugeln was haben sie in
diesem moment gedacht
das ist nicht der richtige
christbaumschmuck ist habe ich gedacht
aber ich habe mich darüber gefreut dass
kinder sich im märz damit
auseinandergesetzt haben und
wahrscheinlich dokumentieren wollten
dass sie nie wieder einen solchen
weihnachtsbaum cocoon agieren sehen
wollen auf jeden fall schmuck den sie
sich zu hause nicht an den baum hängen
werden definitiv nicht die vielen dank
für diese muntere runde
das waren die richtigen fragen uns
gibt's auch nächsten sonntag wieder bis
dahin schönen abend
[Musik]